je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Gérard Longuet avant qu'il la
prenne
mais avant qu'il la prenne
je voudrais saluer Gérard Longuet qui a
pris la décision à la fin de nos
sessions de pas renouveler son mandat il
a été 22 ans dans cette émission il a
été président du groupe UMP et il a été
à la commission des finances j'allais
dire un orateur et quelqu'un qui a donné
toujours beaucoup d'élévation et je
voudrais saluer le travail qu'il a fait
comme président de l'Office
Parlementaire l'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques
bon ça c'était pas prévu
non non
oui oui merci monsieur le Président ce
n'était pas prévu
je souhaite simplement rester d'une
sérénité à toute épreuve car en effet
après 45 ans demanda parlementaire le
jeune Gabriel Attal n'était pas né alors
que j'étais déjà député
c'est pour ça que je le remercie de
répondre à cet instant
avant-hier Bruno Le Maire a inauguré à
installer les premières Assises des
finances publiques comme écrivain je
l'accepte mais très honnêtement comme
metteur en scène il est nul
il s'est trompé de lieu
il y a un lieu pour les finances
publiques ça s'appelle le Parlement
c'est l'Assemblée nationale et c'est le
Sénat
il s'est trompé ensuite il s'est trompé
ensuite parce qu'il y a pas une première
assise et on verra plus tard il y a une
urgence absolue pour redresser les
finances de notre pays et ma question
est d'une grande simplicité même si mon
excellent collègue a pu semble la voir
ouverte et bien je vais enfoncer ma et
le sujet est posé la question suivante
pourquoi diable n'avez-vous pas
répondu à la commande de madame la
Première ministre Elisabeth borne de
présenter
en avril de présenter en juillet la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
23 27
monsieur Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
ministre Gérard Longuet moi je réponds
toujours aux commandes de la première
ministre et j'ai entendu lundi une
commande de la première ministre a
présenté la loi de programmation des
finances publiques au mois de septembre
prochain et donc évidemment nous nous
mettons en ordre de marche avec Bruno Le
Maire pour la présenter en septembre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on la présente en
septembre je pense que c'était ça
derrière votre question parce que ça
davantage de sens de la présenter avec
le projet de loi de finances étant donné
les choix budgétaires majeurs que nous
allons devoir faire dans le cadre du PLF
pour qu'il soit intégré dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
plutôt que de représenter une loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
juillet et de devoir revenir ensuite en
septembre après la présentation du PLF
pour adapter le texte raison pour
laquelle nous reviendrons avec cette
programmation dont je rappelle qu'elle
avait été adoptée au Sénat avec un
quantum d'économie très important
supplémentaire qui avait été décidé par
votre assemblée je pense que ça sera
intéressant qu'on puisse avoir le débat
désormais sur où est-ce vous situez ces
économies supplémentaires et on
partagera chacun nos propositions et on
pourra échanger sur ce sujet là puisque
une fois avoir arbitré un quantum je
pense que c'est important d'être capable
de dire où est-ce que on identifie les
économies dans chaque périmètre
ministériel voilà
[Musique]